we have new details this morning from
the Sheriff's Department investigating
that bizarre kidnapping of a California
mother sherry Pappy knee was held
against her will for three weeks
she was found Thanksgiving morning her
husband's telling ABC News about the
very scary circumstances around her
release she had a middle
sorryi chain around her waist that is
correct she had a bag of her head they
opened the door she doesn't know because
she had a bag of her head they cut
something to free her restraint that was
holding her into the vehicle and then
kind of pushed her out very scary stuff
that penny is now trying to help police
find her captors Marvy area is outside
the Shasta County Sheriff's Office in
Redding California with the descriptions
that she gave investigators Maria good
morning good morning Gail definitely a
scary situation indeed the Shasta County
Sheriff's Department is working with the
FBI right now on this case and they say
sherry Pappy knee has been very
courageous and cooperative during this
entire ordeal during her interviews but
they also say that although she has
given them a lot of information about
her suspects and her time in captivity
they still don't have a good description
of those two women who are still at
large and considered dangerous we're
thankful the sherry has been United with
her family
sherry Pappy nee told police the two
women who allegedly abducted her spoke
in Spanish and tried to hide their
identities sherry did her best that she
could in providing the descriptions but
was not able to provide a detailed
description through the suspects
covering their faces and at times
Sherry's head was covered the sheriff
says Pappy knee described one of the
suspects as having long curly hair
pierced ears and thin eyebrows the
second is an older woman with straight
black hair with hints of gray and thick
eyebrows investigators are trying to
work with a sketch artist to create
drawings of the suspects they don't know
if they targeted Pappy knee or if this
was a random abduction until we identify
the suspects the public should remain
cautious
during the 22 day she was in captivity
Pappy nee says she was beaten and
branded she was released on the side of
this Northern California highway about a
hundred and fifty miles from her home
investigators are now processing the
clothes she was found in for DNA
evidence
the sheriff says puppy's own memories
could be crucial to solving the case but
that could take time sometimes people
that undergo extreme instances or trauma
they the mind can end up blocking out
information and recollection detectives
recently showed Pappy nee a lot of
surveillance video that had SUVs in them
on the day that she was taken the
abduction day which was on November 2nd
poppy knee looked at that video Nora and
said that none of them were the SUV that
she was taken in hmm Mariah thank you so
much